Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cette semaine, je me suis rendu à la RTBF pour interviewer Jérôme Colin.
Ça a mis un peu de temps à se faire. On l'avait rapidement évoqué quand j'avais interviewé Myriam Leroy en janvier.
Myriam me disait qu'elle n'avait pas détesté l'école, mais que par contre, elle me recommandait d'en parler avec Jérôme.
C'est chose faite, puisqu'en plus de tous les problèmes d'adultes que j'espère ne jamais connaître, comme la parentalité, les vieux couples, son rapport à la mortalité, au succès.
Dans cet épisode, on a aussi discuté ensemble de l'école et de la situation de ses enfants. Il est un peu plus court que d'habitude, mais il y aura les annonces en fin d'épisode.
Bonne écoute. Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, nous sommes avec Jérôme Colin. Jérôme Colin, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Tu es animateur à la RTBF, en télévision pour Hep Taxi et en radio en quotidienne pour Entrez sans frapper sur La Première.
Tout à fait.
D'ailleurs, tu vas enregistrer juste après, tu vas filer en studio dans une petite heure.
Question que je pose à tous les journalistes que j'ai interviewés jusqu'à présent. C'est une question bateau, mais les réponses sont toujours intéressantes à mon avis.
Comment est-ce que tu es tombé dans le journalisme ? Comment ça t'est arrivé ?
Par hasard. Au début, moi, je voulais être comédien et donc je suis allé à Paris faire le cours Florent dans la classe libre.
J'ai passé trois ans là-bas, mais j'étais très jeune. J'avais dix-sept ans et demi quand je suis parti, et le monde du théâtre ne me correspondait pas.
J'étais trop petit encore, j'avais pas encore assez de maturité. Et donc après trois ans, je détestais tellement ce petit monde dans lequel j'étais voué quand même à passer ma vie que je suis revenu.
Et je suis revenu, j'ai rencontré une jeune fille qui est devenue ma femme et je me suis dit : « Merde, qu'est-ce que je fais dans la vie ?
» Boum. Je me suis dit : « Oh, écrire, ce serait bien, faire de la radio peut-être ». Mais j'y avais jamais vraiment pensé quand même.
Et donc je me suis inscrit en communication pour que ce soit un peu—
Ok, à l'unif ?
Non, à la rue de la Poste—
D'accord.
...à Saint-Josse et à l'ISFSC où j'étais avec Xavier Vanbuggenhout, par exemple—
...avec qui je partage beaucoup de temps d'antenne ici à la RTBF maintenant. Et Hakima Darmouch aussi qui est à la RTBF, qui était dans ma classe. Et,
et petit à petit, j'ai commencé à aimer ça. Et à l'école, on a commencé à faire des stages. Évidemment, j'étais en communication, je devais faire du journalisme, je suis allé dans des journaux,
je suis allé au Soir, je suis allé au Soir Magazine, je suis allé au Moustique.
Et puis je suis venu à la RTBF. Et à la RTBF, parce que quand même, la parole, l'usage de la parole entre le fait d'être comédien et le fait— c'était quand même un lien très fort.
Et j'écoutais beaucoup l'émission de Jacques de Pierpont à l'époque, Rock A Gogo. Et j'ai demandé à faire un stage chez Jacques de Pierpont à Rock A Gogo et c'était en deuxième année.
Et en fait, je ne suis plus jamais parti de la RTBF. J'ai commencé à travailler quelques mois après mon stage et donc ma troisième année d'études, je travaillais déjà ici un petit peu.
Et puis quand je suis sorti, j'ai été engagé. Donc c'était plutôt facile. Donc plutôt pas une vocation de jeune homme, mais quelque chose dans lequel je suis tombé un petit peu par hasard et qui m'a beaucoup plu.
Quand on avait reçu dans cette émission il y a quelques mois, Dan Gagnon—
...qui regardait la Belgique d'un point de vue extérieur—
Ouais.
...comme un expat, il était assez critique de— enfin, critique, non, il n'emploierait pas ce mot-là, mais un petit peu quand même—
...de voilà, cette culture belge qu'il appelait culture d'immobilisme où on ne sort pas trop des sentiers battus, on reste très fort sur les rails.
Et donc toi, tu fais un petit peu le ménestrel, tu es devenu journaliste.
Qu'est-ce qui explique que dans un premier temps, tu te sois dirigé vers le théâtre, que tu sois sorti des rails finalement,
plutôt que de rester, de faire l'unif, de faire un master, d'avoir une beauté de la société ?
J'aimais pas l'école, donc—
Yes.
...faire de longues études, déjà, c'était hors de question. J'étais plutôt bon à l'école en plus. C'était pas une question de souffrir pour réussir.
C'était pas du tout ça, c'était juste que ça m'étouffait. Donc une fois que j'ai eu ma sixième humanité, je me suis dit : « Je me barre à Paris tout de suite, je vais faire du théâtre, je ne veux plus être assis sur un banc ».
Puis en grandissant, j'ai retrouvé de nouveau un sens. Et donc quand je suis revenu de Paris, j'ai réaccepté. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut faire quelque chose de différent ?
J'en sais rien, moi. Je viens d'une famille très normative. Mon père travaillait au chemin de fer, ma maman ne travaillait pas, elle nous éduquait, mon frère et moi.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi certains ont envie de prendre un petit peu la tangente et de sortir du cadre alors que d'autres restent dans le cadre.
Pourquoi des gens à dix-huit ans veulent aller habiter à dix mille kilomètres de chez eux alors qu'il y en a plein qui meurent à deux kilomètres de l'endroit où ils sont nés ?
Je ne sais pas à quoi c'est dû. Probablement une certaine anxiété. Très tôt, moi, j'ai eu très peur de mourir jeune et donc je crois que je me suis dit : « Alors fais des trucs tant qu'il est temps ».
Ouais.
Très tôt, bouge, vois le monde, rencontre des gens. Et je crois que c'est cette peur-là qui a fait que je me suis mis en marche.
Parce que dans ton bouquin, donc Le Champ de bataille, à un moment donné, tu dis, même si c'est le narrateur qui dit, même si on se doute qu'il y a beaucoup de Jérôme Colin—
Il y a quelque chose quand même.
Voilà. À un moment donné, le narrateur dit : « En Belgique, on a préféré mettre l'accent sur la discipline, le feutre rouge, la hiérarchie, le rang, le silence ».
Donc tu dépeins une Belgique qui est finalement très carrée.
En tout cas en enseignement. L'enseignement—
Pour l'enseignement ?
...le rouge, le silence. Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Tu penses, ça ne dépasse pas l'enseignement ?
Eh, si, si, c'est une bonne question. C'est un peu l'immobilisme, l'ordre, le feutre rouge, c'est-à-dire la punition, hein—
...quand on sort du cadre, etc. Moi, c'est une société qui ne me plaît pas. J'aime pas l'autoritarisme.
Ouais.
Ça ne me plaît pas. Je trouve que c'est très utile, hein, d'avoir des flashs sur les bords des routes parce que ça évite que des gens meurent, mais en même temps, c'est très agressif, la punition.
Et quand un État se permet de demander cent cinquante euros à des gens qui ont roulé vingt à l'heure trop vite, ce qui, je pense, est explicable parce que ça sauve des vies et c'est très bien, il faut faire ça.
Je pense que l'État oublie une chose, c'est que pour certaines personnes, pour certains d'entre nous, payer cent cinquante euros sur un mois, c'est trop.
C'est-à-dire que la punition, elle est disproportionnée. Probablement. Il y a des gens qui sont vraiment dans la merde pendant plusieurs semaines, voire plusieurs mois.
Et je pense que l'État ne peut pas faire ça. L'État peut prévenir, il doit utiliser les meilleures manières, évidemment, pour qu'il y ait le moins de morts possible, pour qu'on soit responsable, pour qu'on ne mette pas la vie des autres en danger.
Mais par contre, les punitions sont toujours très fortes. Et on est dans un pays où la punition est tout à fait réelle et ça, je la trouve dérangeante.
Et c'est vrai que le flicage de manière générale de la société me dérange, l'autorité à l'école me dérange, l'autorité dans l'entreprise, moi, je travaille ici à la RTBF, elle me dérange très fort quand elle est abusive.
Et on a toujours quand même de l'autorité au-dessus de nous. On n'est pas libre pour un bal quoi, par contre. Et ça, c'est quelque chose qui me chipote pas mal, ouais.
Oui oui. Et donc cette attitude, certains appelleraient une attitude rebelle—
Ouais, très gentiment, hein.
Tu dis que ça te vient d'une peur de la mortalité que t'as eue très jeune. Pourquoi, quelle raison est-ce que t'as eu peur de mourir quand t'avais seize ans ?
J'en sais rien. J'ai vu des gens mourir très tôt, moi, dans la vie et de très près, chez moi. Et donc j'ai vu ce que c'était la mort quand j'étais un petit garçon, à deux reprises, et je pense que ça m'a traumatisé.
Et donc cette peur, elle est née chez moi de manière très vivace parce que je pouvais visualiser ce que c'était.
Et donc je pense que c'est véritablement ça qui a créé beaucoup de traumas chez moi et beaucoup de choses pour lesquelles je m'en sors toujours pas.
Mais par contre, c'est vrai que c'est probablement cette chose-là aussi qui m'a mis en marche pour essayer d'avoir une vie un petit peu plus différente que celle à laquelle j'étais a priori voué en naissant à Flawinne, près de Namur,
d'une famille très normative, pas très riche,
et très heureuse, hein, par contre, très très bien, pleine d'amour, hein, mais j'aurais dû rester là, voilà.
Et ça s'est passé un petit peu différemment. Alors ma vie, c'est pas non plus Hollywood, hein, mais elle est plus surprenante que celle à laquelle j'avais initialement pensé.
Ouais. Là, je me retrouve un petit peu dans ton discours puisque je me souviens que moi, quand j'avais seize, dix-sept ans et que tout d'un coup, il était question de savoir qu'est-ce que j'allais faire dans la vie et que
je voyais devant moi s'étendre cinquante ans de métro, boulot, dodo.
Et je voyais effectivement le— j'imaginais directement le cercueil au bout de cette route.
Je ne pensais qu'à ça. Et donc effectivement, un peu comme toi, j'ai cherché à échapper à ce métro, boulot, dodo.
Et donc ton personnage, c'est de nouveau— j'ai la même chose qu'avec Myriam, c'est quand je lis ton livre, je t'imagine toi, en fait.
Oui oui, mais il y a de quoi, hein.
J'ai beaucoup de mal à faire la séparation. Mais donc ton personnage dans le bouquin, il y a toute une page où il parle de, voilà, de : « Tout avait disparu.
Combien de temps reste-t-il pour s'aimer quand vous devez vous réveiller à l'aube, préparer le petit déjeuner, torcher un cul, ramasser du vomi, donner à manger, changer le linge, habiller l'enfant, calmer ses pleurs.
» Et ça continue comme ça pendant toute une page. Tous les jours, non-stop, jusqu'à la fin de sa vie. Est-ce que toi, en étant journaliste, est-ce que tu échappes à ce métro, boulot, dodo, à cette routine quotidienne ?
Non. Évidemment que non. Je pense que personne n'y échappe, sauf les gens qui sont capables d'un certain égoïsme. C'est-à-dire que des gens qui se pensent assez puissants,
pour s'imaginer seuls au monde et pour qui la souffrance des autres n'est pas grand-chose.
Ceux-là, je pense qu'ils parviennent à échapper à cette routine meurtrière du métro, boulot, dodo. Moi, j'ai pas l'égoïsme nécessaire à ça.
Quel rapport entre la souffrance des autres et le métro, boulot, dodo ?
Parce que si vous échappez à métro, boulot, dodo, c'est-à-dire aux charges du quotidien, à vous occuper de vos enfants,
à consacrer du temps à la femme avec laquelle vous vivez ou l'homme avec lequel vous vivez, à servir votre patron du mieux que vous le pouvez, etc., etc.
Si vous voulez échapper à ça, vous blessez les autres. Si vous vous occupez pas de vos enfants, ça veut dire que votre femme va devoir le faire à votre place.
Si vous vous occupez pas de votre femme, elle va être malheureuse, etc., etc. Donc consacrer du temps aux autres, ça fait partie de métro, boulot, dodo.
Il y en a pour qui c'est une joie. Moi, c'est une joie chez moi. Mais si on veut échapper à ça, il faut échapper au reste.
Et si on échappe au reste, ça veut dire qu'on oublie ces obligations et on les refile à quelqu'un d'autre qui va devoir les remplir.
C'est dégueulasse, mais ça s'appelle l'égoïsme. Et ceux-là, je pense, par contre, parviennent à avoir des vies qui sortent de métro, boulot, dodo.
Mais par contre, à quels frais ? Moi, j'y parviens absolument pas. Et le fait d'être journaliste ou pas, vraiment non, parce que j'ai une famille.
Donc, métro, boulot, dodo, je peux te dire que c'est très très très très incarné parce que, bah, il y a une routine de la famille qui existe.
Il faut s'occuper des enfants, il faut les élever, il faut leur faire la bouffe, il faut laver leur linge, il faut nettoyer la maison.
Enfin, comme tout le monde. J'ai des patrons ici à la RTBF et j'ai beau leur dire que j'ai une émission de radio et une émission de télé, je peux te dire qu'ils s'en foutent.
Parce que tous leurs employés sont comme moi. Donc non, non, je suis en plein dans ce système-là qui me déplaît.
J'aimerais ne pas en faire partie, donc j'essaye d'avoir le plus possible de chemins d'échappement, de chemins d'évitement.
Le fait d'écrire, par exemple, des livres en est un, le fait de partir en vacances en est un, le fait d'avoir un jardin secret en est un, le fait de— etc., etc.
Mais de manière générale, non, je suis enchaîné absolument comme tout le monde, il y a pas de raison.
Ta peur de la mortalité, elle a disparu ? Elle est toujours là ? Tu penses—
Non parce qu'aux dernières nouvelles, je vais toujours mourir.
Oui, oui, bien sûr.
J'ai pas de nouvelles réjouissantes de ce côté-là encore.
Ton attitude par rapport à ça, est-ce qu'elle a évolué par rapport à l'adolescent qui avait peur de sa mortalité et qui voulait absolument—
Non, c'est la première chose à laquelle je pense le matin quand je me réveille tous les matins. C'est comme ça.
C'est bizarre.
Bah ouais, on a beau voir des psys, on a beau essayer de faire autre chose. Non, c'est avec cette pensée-là que je me réveille.
Encore un jour, c'est bien. Mais t'inquiète, ça va frapper un jour. Comme ça, moi, je vis comme ça. Mais après, quand c'est tous les jours, c'est moins catastrophique que ça n'y paraît aussi hein.
Mais c'est des cerveaux qui fonctionnent comme ça.
Yes. On a parlé dès le début, tu l'as évoqué, de l'école et de ton malaise par rapport à l'école.
Est-ce que ton malaise par rapport à l'école a guidé ton approche parentale par rapport à tes enfants à toi ?
Est-ce que ça a guidé l'école que tu as choisie pour eux, la façon dont tu les encadres par rapport à l'école ?
Oui, ça l'a modifié. Ça n'a servi à rien, mais ça l'a modifié parce qu'effectivement, moi, j'ai été un étudiant plutôt relaxe parce que je réussissais, c'était facile, etc., etc.
Par contre, au point de vue du comportement, comme on dit, dans les journaux de classe, c'était plus compliqué avec des renvois, etc.
Mais ce qui m'avait déplu dans l'école, c'est l'enfermement. C'est vraiment l'impression que j'avais d'enfermement et de perdre mon temps.
J'avais l'impression que la vie commencerait quand j'allais sortir de l'école. Et j'ai eu ça toujours. Et donc quand mes enfants sont rentrés à l'école, quand même vingt-cinq ans après que j'en sois sorti, hein, finalement.
Non, c'est pas vrai, c'est une connerie que je dis là. Quand mes enfants sont rentrés à l'école, vingt-cinq ans après que moi, j'y suis rentré, en gros, je me suis dit qu'elle avait changé, cette école.
Tu espérais.
Ouais, j'espérais que ça avait changé parce que quand même, la société, elle, par contre, avait quand même beaucoup évolué et très vite.
Et en fait, on a beau eu choisir des écoles plus proximiteuses, plus alternatives, etc. En fait, dans l'absolu, rien n'a changé, non.
On a beau être, remettre le système en question, on a beau chercher des alternatives, pas moyen de trouver.
Non, parce qu'un enfant n'est pas l'autre. Et donc quand on a plusieurs enfants, déjà, il faut une question d'organisation derrière tout ça.
Et puis le fait qu'il y ait certaines écoles qui soient alternatives et potentiellement très bonnes ne m'intéresse pas.
Ce qui m'intéresse, moi, c'est la société dans laquelle je vis. C'est pas que mes enfants, c'est tous les enfants. C'est-à-dire que ce que je veux, c'est une égalité dans la société dans laquelle on vit.
C'est quand même ça, vers ça qu'on doit tendre tous. Alors que moi, parce que je suis privilégié, je puisse mettre mes enfants dans une école un peu plus loin, un peu plus chère, un peu plus performante, un peu plus bienveillante, etc.
En fait, dans l'absolu, ça ne m'intéresse pas. Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est que la société dans laquelle je vis soit égalitaire et que tous les enfants puissent bénéficier d'une école qui leur convienne et surtout bienveillante.
Or, ce n'est pas le cas.
D'accord, donc tu penses à tous les enfants avant de penser à tes propres enfants.
Non, non, je pense à mes propres enfants d'abord, mais philosophiquement, ça ne m'intéresse pas. C'est pas une question qui m'intéresse, savoir dans quelle école mes enfants vont.
Ce qui m'intéresse par rapport à l'école, c'est de savoir à quelle école ont droit tous les enfants de notre pays, à savoir une école catastrophique, puisque la Belgique, les cotes de la Belgique en termes scolaires, c'est catastrophique.
Trente-cinq pour cent des enfants de neuf ans ne savent pas bien lire. Ce qui veut dire que trente-cinq pour cent des enfants, plus tard, décrochent des secondaires hein, sans obtention de CEB, de CESS à la fin.
Ce qui veut dire que nous sommes champions du monde en termes de redoublement en Belgique, on est champions du monde en termes d'exclusion pour mille élèves et on est à la ramasse totale dans tous les tests PISA.
C'est-à-dire que notre bulletin, il est archi mauvais, archi mauvais. Et il y a même eu une étude sur le degré de satisfaction des étudiants en Europe et les Belges arrivaient dans le tiercé de fin. C'est-à-dire que—
La Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, et si je me souviens bien, les Flamands se débrouillaient mieux que—
Se débrouillent mieux. Mais quand même, ce qui veut dire que chez nous, à tous les niveaux, tous les niveaux, l'enseignement est défaillant.
Et je ne vois quand même pas beaucoup de gens s'exciter à ce sujet. Or, l'enseignement, c'est la clé de la société de demain.
On le sait tous que si l'éducation est bonne,
si l'enseignement est bon,
si on parvient à la connaissance, si on fait de bons lecteurs qui pourront avoir du libre arbitre, critiquer le système dans lequel ils sont et pas avaler tout ce qu'on va leur dire, ça, on pourra faire société ensemble.
Si jamais l'école ne le fait pas, nous ne pourrons pas faire société ensemble. Et donc la question est primordiale. Et je ne comprends pas comment un pays comme le nôtre,
qui a des notes aussi négatives sur pratiquement tous les segments étudiés dans l'enseignement, je ne comprends pas comment nous ne sommes pas tous dans la rue pour nos enfants.
Le nombre de parents qui ont eu l'occasion de comparer le système, je ne sais pas, le système suédois, le système belge, le système allemand, le système belge pour voir : Ah effectivement, c'est mieux ailleurs.
Tout vient de l'éducation.
Ça doit pas être nombreux.
Mais tout vient de l'éducation.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord. Et comment est-ce que tu expliques... Oui, oui, donc, tu ne l'expliques pas, en fait, la raison pour laquelle—
Si, si, la bêtise.
La bêtise ?
Oui, la bêtise, l'opportunisme politique. C'est-à-dire qu'on n'a jamais eu de ministre de l'enseignement ici qui était capable de révolutionner un système.
Le paquebot est tellement lourd à faire bouger, le paquebot de l'enseignement, tellement lourd. C'est-à-dire que si vous touchez quoi que ce soit, des droits des instits, des profs, etc.
C'est très difficile, évidemment, parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie qu'on touche à leurs droits. Et je les comprends, d'une certaine manière, le métier qu'ils font, il est extrêmement difficile.
Mais l'institution qui les pilote, elle ne veut pas le meilleur. Elle ne veut pas le meilleur. Sinon, on ne serait pas à la ramasse dans tous les segments de l'enseignement.
Et aujourd'hui, la seule chose sur laquelle on peut théoriser, c'est la bêtise de la classe politique de chez nous. C'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas assez d'intelligence dans la classe politique aujourd'hui pour pouvoir gérer l'enseignement de notre pays.
Et ce n'est pas une insulte de le dire. Il suffit de regarder les résultats. C'est-à-dire que les résultats sont mauvais et rien ne change.
À part la bêtise, je ne vois pas ce qui peut empêcher le changement.
Il y a des réformes qui sont en cours. Côté francophone, il y a le pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence. Quand tu regardes ça, est-ce que tu es empli d'espoir et tu dis : Enfin, enfin, c'est le début d'un bon enseignement.
Non, non, non. Je l'ai lu, c'est...
Tu n'es pas convaincu ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il n'y a rien dedans qui puisse appeler à un enseignement d'excellence demain. Et le mot excellence, déjà, il est moche parce qu'il y a des enfants qui ne sont pas excellents, en fait, qui sont juste bons ou pas très bons.
Mais ça n'empêche pas qu'on doit être bienveillants envers eux. Et je pense que le mot bienveillance n'existe pas d'ailleurs dans le pacte d'excellence, alors qu'il aurait dû être au fronton du pacte d'excellence.
Parce que c'est pas des élèves qui sont à l'école, c'est des enfants. Et un enfant, ça a besoin de bienveillance, un point, c'est tout.
Donc non, non, non, j'y crois pas du tout.
Pas du tout convaincu ? Y a rien qui, rien qui—
Non, non, surtout que l'implémentation finale, a priori, c'est 2024. Et en 2024, tu sais, le monde, il aura encore changé très très fort.
On n'est qu'en 2019, 2024, ce sera déjà un monde différent à la vitesse à laquelle il va.
Donc, 2029, n'en parlons pas. Et donc, en 2024, quand le pacte d'excellence sera implémenté, il faudra déjà changer parce que le monde nous aura déjà dépassés une nouvelle fois.
Si le constat, c'est : l'enseignement en Belgique, c'est de la merde, c'est pas au niveau, je suis très déçu, moi, Jérôme Colin, je ne crois pas en ce système,
pourquoi est-ce que tu mets tes enfants à l'école et tu ne te dis pas : je vais—
Parce que déjà, c'est leur choix. C'est pas à moi de décider pour eux. Hein—
Comme un poux.
Non, non, non, non. C'est pas à moi de décider pour eux. Ils sont grands, moi, mes enfants.
Oui, aujourd'hui.
Ils ont 16, 17 et 18 ans. Donc c'est pas du tout à moi de décider pour eux.
Donc si demain, ils t'annonçaient : ''L'école, j'en ai marre.'' Tu dirais d'accord ?
Oui, oui, parce qu'il y en a un chez moi qui va pas à l'école.
OK. Donc, OK, donc c'est le cas.
Le cadet, chez moi, il va pas à l'école parce qu'il veut pas y aller. Et c'est très compliqué d'ailleurs, parce que ça te met dans une certaine incertitude, parce que c'est vrai que le système,
le récit, comme dit Yuval Harari, de notre société, c'est : tu vas aller à l'école, tu vas apprendre.
Si t'apprends, tu pourras avoir un métier, tu gagneras de l'argent, t'auras une femme et un chien et tu seras heureux.
Ça, c'est le récit de la société dans laquelle on vit. Quand un de vos enfants va plus à l'école, ce récit s'effondre.
Et vous réalisez que les
alternatives sont pas nombreuses, en fait. On n'offre pas grand-chose dans notre pays aux enfants qui ne veulent pas aller à l'école ou qui ne peuvent pas aller à l'école ou qui ne savent pas aller à l'école ou qui sont empêchés d'aller à l'école
ou qui n'ont pas le niveau, comme l'école dit : ''Il n'a pas le niveau pour rester dans notre école.''
La formule que tu emploies dans le livre, c'est : ''Un fruit est pourri, il faut—''
''Il y a une pomme pourrie, on la retire du bac.''
C'est ça.
Ouais, tout à fait. Moi, je l'ai entendu, pour un de mes enfants. Et pourtant, celui-là, il est encore à l'école.
Donc oui, moi, j'ai un enfant qui va pas à l'école et je lui laisse le droit de ne pas aller à l'école s'il ne veut vraiment pas aller à l'école.
J'ai insisté, franchement, pour qu'il y aille, parce que je veux qu'il rentre dans ce récit d'une certaine manière, parce que je suis victime de ce récit, moi aussi, de la société dans laquelle je vis.
Tu veux qu'il souffre.
Je veux pas qu'il souffre. Le récit de la société dans laquelle je vis, c'est : tu vas à l'école, tu gagnes de l'argent, t'es heureux, t'as une femme, t'as un chien et tout va bien.
Et je suis imprégné de ce récit, parce qu'en plus, j'en suis le fruit, parce que je suis allé à l'école.
Ouais.
Mais lui n'en est pas imprégné. Et lui a dû me convaincre qu'il ne voulait pas aller à l'école. Et j'ai accepté à la fin qu'il n'aille pas à l'école parce qu'il y était malheureux.
Et donc, moi, je veux pas qu'il soit malheureux.
Comment est-ce que tu expliques son malheur alors que ses deux frères, son frère et sa sœur, je ne sais plus, n'ont pas eu de soucis.
Comment est-ce que tu expliques que—
Ils ont tous des soucis à l'école. Ils ne l'aiment pas. Ils y vont, ils réussissent, etc. Mais ils ne l'aiment pas.
Ils n'aiment pas. Si tu leur demandes s'ils aiment bien l'école, ils vont te dire non. Ils aiment bien avoir des copains à l'école, etc.
Mais la façon dont on leur apprend les choses, ce qu'on leur apprend, le système scolaire, l'autorité, la hiérarchie, les profs, le pion, le proviseur.
Non, ça ne leur plaît pas. La clochette qui sonne, non, ça leur plaît pas. Maintenant, pourquoi il y en a un qui décroche ou qui refuse d'y aller et les autres pas ?
Ça, c'est des questions de personnalité, c'est des questions de parcours, c'est des questions de trauma, c'est des questions d'être touché plus par quelque chose qu'un autre.
Je constate quand même que celui qui a décroché chez moi, c'est celui qui est le plus poreux au monde extérieur, qui est le plus touché par l'extérieur.
Et je pense qu'il a été blessé quelque part par l'école et qu'un jour, il a refusé d'y aller, oui.
OK.
Mais l'école ne prend pas ses responsabilités par rapport à ça. Elle n'accepte pas.
Oui, c'est sûr, oui. On est assez d'accord. Le seul point où j'ai un petit hic, c'est quand tu disais,
voilà : ''La classe politique devrait prendre ses responsabilités.'' Est trop remplie de bêtises pour le faire, est trop incompétente.
Parce qu'il y a pas aussi la nature de la Belgique où on a un système politique en forme de couches, en forme de lasagnes où—
Oui, oui, tout ça est responsable. L'électoralisme, la lasagne institutionnelle, c'est responsable, etc. Mais moi, je vote pour des gens et je leur demande d'avoir du courage.
Mh.
Parce que j'ai le courage de voter pour eux, alors que j'ai pas déjà totalement confiance en eux au début. Et pourtant, j'ai le courage de voter pour eux.
Donc, je leur demande en retour un certain courage. Or, du courage politique, sans faire d'électoralisme, moi, quand même, je constate que c'est des gens qui ont très envie de faire une carrière en politique et donc d'être réélus.
Et c'est pas ce que je leur demande. Moi, je m'en fous de leur carrière. Ce que je leur demande, c'est des actes. Ce que je leur demande, c'est de l'intelligence que je n'ai pas, de la puissance que je n'ai pas,
de la capacité d'organisation que je n'ai pas, de la capacité de rassemblement que je n'ai pas, parce que si je l'avais, je serais à leur place.
Eux, ils se sont présentés. Ils ont eu cette fierté de dire : ''Je peux représenter le peuple dans lequel je vis. Je peux le faire.'' Si tu as cette fierté, derrière, t'assumes.
Tu ne fais pas de faux semblants, tu ne fais pas de communication. Tu as un discours honnête, réaliste. Or, je ne les vois pas faire ça.
Et c'est vrai que quand je vois la capacité d'expression, par exemple, orale, quand j'entends un débat de politique en France ou en Angleterre et quand j'entends un débat de politique ici en Belgique, c'est triste.
C'est triste. Ils s'expriment moins bien, ils ont moins de vocabulaire, ils ont moins de connaissances, etc. Et donc c'est vrai qu'ils sont en dessous quand même.
Ce que moi j'apprécie, quand je regarde les débats, par exemple en comparant la France et la Belgique, c'est qu'en France, ça tourne vite au clash, à la petite phrase, on s'emporte en plateau télé, etc.
Ici, tu as Didier Reynders et Joëlle Milquet en plateau. Ils se quittent en se faisant la bise, en disant : ''On se retrouve la semaine prochaine.'' Parce que y a cette culture de coalition où—
Oui, oui. Après, moi, faut pas dire ce que je veux pas dire. Je suis pas antipolitique du tout. Je n'aime pas la politique, ça me passionne pas parce que je suis déçu.
Mh.
Après, je suis pas antipolitique. Moi, je pense qu'il faut un gouvernement pour pouvoir vivre dans une société.
Je suis pas anarchiste. Donc, on a besoin, on a besoin d'eux. Mais c'est vrai qu'on aurait besoin, a priori, d'une meilleure version d'eux.
Yes. Quand toi, tu avais des petites lettres B, TB, S, danger, satisfaction, insatisfaction—
Mmh.
Je ne sais plus comment on appelle ça—
Quand j'étais coté quoi.
Oui, c'est ça. Quand tu avais des cotes pour te noter en tant que personne au sein de l'école, et que donc toi, tu disais parfois des mauvaises notes en comportement.
Mmh-mmh.
J'ai eu ça aussi parfois. Est-ce que c'est arrivé que tes enfants reviennent à la maison avec de telles—
Évidemment.
Oui ?
Évidemment, j'ai des enfants turbulents à l'école. Donc oui, oui, oui. Et plus fréquemment—
Est-ce que tu vois ça comme une mauvaise chose ou comme une bonne chose ? Comment est-ce que tu vois ça ?
Non, je vois ça comme une chose normale, parce que quand on est adolescent, se rebeller contre un ordre établi, c'est quand même un mouvement normal.
Or, ce que je constate, c'est que l'école n'est pas d'accord.
Elle ne laisse pas les adolescents être des adolescents. C'est-à-dire que l'école voudrait que les adolescents ne se rebellent pas contre elle, alors qu'elle, elle représente l'autorité.
Or, un adolescent, dans son sang, il y a ça, dans son cerveau, il y a ça : Je vais me rebeller contre l'autorité, je vais me rebeller contre le monde qu'on me propose parce que moi, j'en ferai un monde différent.
C'est ça, être adolescent. Et l'école n'est pas d'accord avec le fait qu'ils soient adolescents, avec leur ADN d'adolescent.
Ce qui est ridicule, évidemment, vu qu'ils l'ont en eux.
Mmh-mmh.
Ils ne le font pas exprès. Ils sont comme ça. Et ce que je n'aime pas dans l'école, c'est normal à un moment que l'école dise : Votre fils, il a fait ça, votre fils, il a fait ça, il faut pas qu'il le fasse.
C'est normal. Ce que je n'aime pas derrière, c'est l'acharnement. C'est l'acharnement qui peut aller à la malveillance et à la cruauté de certains adultes envers certains enfants.
Ça, ça me plaît pas partout.
Tu penses à quoi, par exemple ? Tu as quelque chose vu de la—
J'ai vu des profs s'acharner sur des élèves.
Mmh-mmh.
Et avoir des comportements absolument inacceptables vis-à-vis d'élèves. Dire des choses inacceptables à des élèves, être sur le dos d'élèves bien particuliers plutôt que d'autres, de manière tout à fait réelle.
Évidemment, je l'ai vu une fois de plus. À quoi on peut attribuer ça ? La bêtise.
Mmh-mmh. La bêtise.
Oui.
L'incompétence. Il me semble avoir entendu dans une
interview que tu avais faite précédemment, tu évoquais le caractère, un autre caractère spécifique de l'enseignement en Belgique qui est très majoritairement catholique ou majoritairement.
Donc c'est soixante—
Cinquante-deux pour cent, je pense.
Est-ce que tu vois ça comme un facteur qui ralentit l'évolution ? Qui—
Ben évidemment, il y a un certain conservatisme dans l'école catholique. C'est sûr que si on doit avancer, la vitesse à laquelle avance le monde aujourd'hui est effrayante, je veux dire.
On peut pas le suivre. C'est-à-dire qu'un État ne peut plus suivre des entreprises privées qui vont à deux mille à l'heure.
Un État est trop lourd à diriger pour pouvoir le suivre et pouvoir prendre des décisions aussi vite. Bon, on est condamné.
Mais si en plus, c'est l'école catholique qui, en plus, est extrêmement conservatrice, c'est sûr qu'on est largué.
Mmh.
C'est sûr qu'on est cinquante ans en retard et que l'an prochain, on sera soixante ans en retard et que dans deux ans, on sera septante ans en retard et dans trois ans, on sera quatre-vingts ans en retard.
Le monde va tellement vite qu'on va cumuler un retard monstrueux et que moi, je suis très très très inquiet pour demain.
Le truc le plus emblématique de ça, mon expérience, c'est que je me souviens que,
j'ai allumé la RTBF, la télé un matin, un dimanche matin, et je suis tombé sur une émission de—
un truc laïque le dimanche matin ou quoi, où ils expliquaient, ils faisaient une émission sur l'homosexualité.
C'est en regardant cette émission par hasard, un dimanche matin, que j'ai appris que : Ah ben tiens, l'homosexualité, c'est parfaitement naturel.
C'est un facteur biologique et tout ça. On ne m'avait jamais appris ça à l'école.
C'est pas que c'est naturel ou un facteur biologique, c'est que chacun a exactement le droit de faire ce qu'il veut et ce qu'il peut avec son corps.
Point. Liberté totale.
Déjà, même si c'était pas biologique, même si c'était une décision, ce serait acceptable. Mais c'est quand même intéressant.
C'est quand même important de savoir que c'est quelque chose d'aussi naturel que l'hétérosexualité. Et c'est quelque chose qu'on ne m'a jamais dit, quand j'étais à l'école catholique.
Au contraire, j'avais même une prof qui m'avait dit que ce n'était pas naturel.
Ah ben ça, c'est très grave.
C'est très grave.
Eh ben ça, c'est une faute grave.
C'est une faute grave.
C'est une faute, mais—
Qui est le fruit d'un héritage catholique au moins en grande partie.
C'est une faute très grave qu'à l'école, un adulte se permette devant une classe d'enfants de stigmatiser un groupe humain.
Mmh-mmh.
C'est une faute grave. C'est une faute très grave. Il ne faut pas que ça se produise à l'école, parce que c'est ça qui fait des générations de racistes, d'homophobes, etc, etc.
C'est ça.
Donc oui, oui, l'école est là pour apprendre la tolérance. De toute façon, il n'y aura d'autre choix que de tous vivre ensemble et ça va être vachement bien si on y arrive.
Donc, arrêtons d'essayer de séparer les différents groupes parce qu'en fait, il n'y en a qu'un, de groupe, de manière générale, c'est-à-dire des gens qui naissent et qui vont mourir. Point.
Pour avoir ce projet politique-là, une école qui est plus inclusive, plus respectueuse et tout ça-
Évidemment.
Et casser ce conservatisme et casser ce... Ben voilà, il y a aussi un problème de mixité sociale avec les écoles ici en Belgique.
Mmh-mmh.
Pour casser tout ça, révolutionner tout ça, il faut donc beaucoup de courage politique.
Oui.
Tu l'expliques, non pas parce qu'ils veulent se faire réélire.
Oui, après, c'est un peu court, mais pour plein d'autres raisons aussi, mais oui.
Dans les grandes lignes, c'est déjà un bon schéma. C'est un peu une équation sans solution.
Si on a besoin des politiciens et que les politiciens, c'est foutu.
Oui, oui. Je pense que par rapport à l'école, par exemple, c'est foutu. On va être complètement largués et nos résultats vont être de plus en plus catastrophiques quand ceux de ceux qui ont réagi vont être de plus en plus bons.
Donc le fossé, le fossé des connaissances, maintenant, va se creuser très très vite. Et la Belgique va devenir un pays du Moyen Âge très très vite.
J'en suis convaincu à cause de son enseignement.
Et tu crois pas que dans dix ans, tu vas regarder ton fils qui n'a pas voulu aller à l'école et tu vas te dire : Ben en fait, ça a très bien marché pour lui.
Tout le monde devrait faire comme ça.
Ah ben en tant que père, je peux te dire que je l'espère, évidemment. Moi, je suis persuadé qu'il y a une vie à-
Oui.
À côté de l'école. L'école n'est pas persuadée de ça, qu'il y a une vie à côté d'elle.
J'ai, j'ai-
Mais moi, en tant que père-
Oui.
Évidemment, j'en suis persuadé. Je pense que ça va aller. Et évidemment, je l'espère de tout mon cœur puisque c'est mon fils et je l'aime.
Mh. J'ai eu une fois une prof qui, je crois que j'avais genre seize ans, une prof de français qui, à un moment donné,
a sous-entendu : Oui, mais bon, si vous avez des mauvais résultats, c'est pas la fin du monde, hein, l'école, ce n'est pas tout.
Mh.
Elle a dit ça et je me souviens que j'ai dû faire une pause. Eh ouais, elle a raison en fait.
Mmh.
Mais c'était la première fois qu'on me disait ça-
Non.
...en seize ans.
Et ben oui.
Ouais, parce qu'il y a cette espèce de-
T'imagines le gamin qui vraiment a du mal.
Ouais.
Vraiment a du mal et à qui pendant quinze ans, on va dire : « Mais vraiment, t'as du mal, t'es mauvais, t'es pas bon. Ça va être dur pour toi dans la vie ».
Avec quoi il va rentrer dans la vie d'adulte ? Avec uniquement : « Ça va être dur. Ça va être dur, la vie ». Évidemment, ça fait un anxieux.
Yes. Oui, ce que je remarque aussi, c'est que les profs,
quand on n'est pas un élève brillant ou quand on est dissipé à leur cours, prennent ça de manière-- en tout cas, certains profs, de nombreux profs prennent ça de manière très personnelle et sont en colère.
Mmh-mmh.
Sont en colère quand l'élève a de mauvais résultats. Comme si, 'fin voilà, il y a cette espèce de stigmatisation, de culpabilisation.
C'est l'élève qui est responsable, qui me fait du mal à moi, le prof.
Mmh-mmh.
Comment est-ce que tu vois ça ? Comment est-ce que tu expliques ça, cette espèce de psychologie ?
Je n'explique pas parce que je suis pas prof. Maintenant, je comprends que le métier de prof, il soit difficile, hein.
De taper vingt-cinq enfants ou vingt-cinq adolescents toute la journée, moi, je le souhaite à personne, hein. Donc je comprends très bien que leur vie soit compliquée.
Mais ce qui m'étonne toujours, c'est qu'ils défendent l'institution pour laquelle ils travaillent. Moi, par exemple, avec Le champ de bataille, j'ai reçu beaucoup de courriers de profs.
Il y en avait des très sympas, mais il y en avait aussi des très insultants.
Qu'est-ce que t'as reçu comme courrier marrant ?
Oh, j'ai reçu des menaces, j'ai reçu-
D'accord, ouais.
...de tout, de profs et de proviseurs et de directeurs-
Les menaces violentes, menaces de mort et compagnie, c'est souvent quand on chamboule un peu le socle identitaire d'une personne et que la personne se sent-
Oui, 'fin là, c'était les menaces, ça commence quand les gens n'ont plus de mots pour s'exprimer, hein.
C'est ça. Ouais.
Et je pense que ceux qui m'ont menacé n'avaient pas beaucoup de mots, non. Ce qui est très embêtant parce qu'ils étaient profs.
C'est ça. Du coup, dans ton livre, le personnage, il a un petit peu-- ce que je trouvais très amusant, il va chez sa psy.
Mmh-mmh.
Et au bout de quelques séances, il finit par toucher du bout du doigt le fait que, ben il n'a pas vraiment eu une adolescence compliquée.
Il n'a pas vraiment fait sa crise d'adolescence.
Mmh-mmh.
Et il se retrouve à la quarantaine, à un peu tout remettre en question, à être en colère.
En question, ouais.
Voilà, c'est ça. Est-ce que c'est toi, ça ?
Non, non, non. Moi, j'ai fait une crise d'adolescence, mais qui était douce, c'est vrai. Qui était plus ou moins douce.
Hmm, pourquoi j'ai dit non ? En fait, c'est peut-être bien moi, ouais. Ouais, je crois que j'ai eu-
C'est interdit, mais pas remboursé par la sécu.
Non, mais c'est vrai. J'ai eu une plus grosse crise de la quarantaine que je n'ai eu une crise d'adolescence.
C'est ça.
C'est vrai que j'ai plus remis ma vie en question à quarante ans qu'à dix-huit ou qu'à seize.
Ouais.
Si, c'est vrai. En fait, t'as raison. Je vois pas pourquoi j'ai dit non.
De rien. Mais tu penses que c'est lié ?
Que quoi est lié ?
L'ampleur de la crise de l'adolescence et celle de la crise de la quarantaine ?
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, oui. Je pense que si on n'a pas fait de crise d'adolescence, on va faire une grosse crise de la quarantaine.
Et franchement, il y a plus de choses à détruire à quarante qu'à seize. Donc, vaut mieux faire une crise d'adolescence.
Ça s'est passé comment pour toi, ta crise de la quarantaine ?
Mal.
Ouais, c'est tout ?
Ouais.
Tu veux pas nous raconter un peu plus ?
Non.
Mais du coup, dans-- l'autre truc qui est intéressant dans le personnage du bouquin, c'était sa relation avec son père.
Mmh-mmh.
Comment, quand lui-même-- le personnage était lui-même en échec scolaire quand il était ado et son père le faisait culpabiliser : « Qu'est-ce que tu nous fais vivre ?
» etc. Est-ce que, de nouveau, je repose la question, est-ce que c'est toi, ça aussi ou est-ce que c'est juste le personnage ?
C'est le personnage. C'est le personnage parce que je voulais qu'il y ait une similarité entre les deux pères, hein, parce que le père de ce mec-là lui a dit : « Qu'est-ce que tu nous fais vivre ?
Tu nous fais souffrir ». Lui, il pensait ça de ses enfants et je voulais lui faire le trajet pendant le roman qu'il ne pense plus ça.
Mmh-mmh.
En fait, c'est pas son enfant qui le fait souffrir, c'est lui, le requin. C'est lui son propre prédateur.
Et je voulais qu'il comprenne ça pendant le roman. Donc, il fallait, oui, c'était vraiment un truc de roman.
Une formule qui m'a fait me questionner, mais évidemment, je n'ai pas l'âge, je n'ai pas la distance pour savoir si c'est vrai, mais à un moment donné, le personnage, le papa de l'histoire-
Mh.
...il ne le dit pas, mais il le pense très fort. Il dit : « J'ai beau être né vingt-cinq ans avant toi », avant son fils, « nous avons en fait le même âge ».
Oui.
C'est vrai, ça ? Ou qu'est-ce que-
Ouais.
Ah oui oui. Qu'il y a que le corps qui vieillit ?
Moi, j'ai vingt-quatre ans et d'après le site info de la RTBF, il y a une news qui est parue il y a quelques mois, que je consulte à peu près toutes les deux semaines, qui dit
: « L'adolescence, ça continue jusqu'à vingt-quatre ans », en fait.
Mh.
Donc, je regarde ça toutes les deux semaines pour me rassurer.
C'est tardif, l'adolescence. Mais oui, en fait, ce qu'il lui dit, c'est : « J'ai beau avoir des cheveux blancs, un petit peu plus de ventre et des rides au coin des yeux, en fait, on a le même âge, mon vieux ».
Celui auquel on reste tous coincés. Et moi, je suis sûr qu'on reste tous coincés à quelque chose qui se situe entre quinze et vingt-cinq ans.
Mh.
Et qu'en fait, après, oui, on a des responsabilités en plus, mais est-ce qu'on change ? Est-ce qu'on change même de désir ?
J'en suis pas convaincu. Moi, j'ai l'impression d'être pratiquement, hormis physiquement, évidemment, et hormis avec un sac à dos un peu plus lourd de responsabilités, d'anxiété, de peur, etc.
Mais en gros, le même gamin, le même garçon. Je suis capable des mêmes bêtises, de reproduire les mêmes erreurs. Je suis capable de m'enthousiasmer pour les mêmes bêtises.
Je pense vraiment qu'on reste coincé et qu'une grande partie de nous reste coincée à cet âge-là.
Quand je regarde les gens qui ont vingt-cinq ans de plus que moi, pas systématiquement, mais souvent, trop souvent, j'observe quand même un certain degré de condescendance et de : « Moi, j'ai de la bouteille, moi, je sais.
Toi, pfff, immaturité, manque de sagesse. Tu ne sais rien, toi, le jeune ». Donc ouais, ce sont des gens qui ont en fait le même âge que moi, mais qui sont quand même condescendants et quand même-
J'en sais rien, ils sont peut-être tout simplement cons aussi, hein. Je les connais pas.
Certainement.
Donc je sais pas, oui, peut-être qu'il y a une espèce de truc comme quoi j'aurais plus vécu que toi et donc j'ai des conseils à te donner.
Tu penses que c'est faux ? Tu penses qu'ils n'ont pas de conseils à me donner ?
Ouais, je pense que c'est pas possible. C'est tellement compliqué de vivre. Et les vies de chacun sont tellement similaires et tellement différentes que franchement, donner des conseils, il faut laisser ça à quelqu'un d'autre.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux donner comme conseils sur la vie ? Qu'est-ce que tu veux comme conseils essentiels ? Je l'explique dans Le champ de bataille.
Moi, mon père, il m'a donné qu'un seul conseil dans la vie. Il m'a dit : Fais attention aux gens à qui on vient de donner un képi.
C'est-à-dire fais attention aux gens à qui on vient de donner de l'autorité.
D'accord, ouais, OK.
Et c'est les plus dangereux, les petits chefs. Il m'a jamais dit que ça. Et-
Les imposteurs.
Le pire, c'est que j'ai eu plein de problèmes dans ma vie avec des petits chefs, donc j'ai pas du tout écouté ce qu'il m'a dit alors que c'était le seul conseil qu'il m'avait donné.
Et des fois, on me demande si je donne des conseils à mes enfants ou si je donne des conseils à des jeunes journalistes ou à des...
Qui je suis ? Je galère à mort en fait, en réalité. Qui je suis pour donner des conseils ? Et là où je ne galère pas, j'ai eu de la chance.
Parce que si j'ai une émission de radio, une émission de télé, c'est aussi parce que j'étais là au bon endroit, au bon moment.
C'est aussi un facteur chance qui est tout à fait réel. Qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on donne des conseils ? Quel conseil de vie on va donner à quelqu'un ?
Franchement, à part d'être
la personne la plus gentille possible, la plus empathique possible et la plus proche des autres possible, parce que la vie, c'est sûr et certain, c'est les autres, c'est les relations humaines qu'on va entretenir pendant notre trajet ici sur Terre.
À part ça, il n'y a rien, je veux dire, de réel, à part les relations qu'on entretient avec les autres. Donc oui, se concentrer sur les relations des autres.
Mais quand on a dit ça, on a tout dit. Et c'est pas un conseil, c'est vraiment une espèce de truc d'évidence. Attention, la vie, ça va être ta relation avec les autres.
C'est finalement très humble comme approche et peut-être même un petit côté syndrome de l'imposteur quand on te demande-
Non, non, j'ai pas.
De donner des conseils.
Ah bah non, j'ai pas de syndrome de l'imposteur parce que franchement, quand je dis que le facteur chance existe, c'est parce qu'il existe.
Tout à fait. Il faut être au bon endroit, au bon moment. Et pour te prouver que j'ai pas de syndrome de l'imposteur, je pense que franchement, je travaille et que je fais pas mal mon boulot.
Alors des fois, je suis très mauvais, mais des fois, je suis pas mal et des fois, je suis probablement même un peu bon. Et donc c'est pas du tout un truc de fausse modestie.
Je suis normal, je suis dans la moyenne, si tu veux.
Mh.
Mais c'est sûr que pour être dans la moyenne, il m'a fallu avoir de la chance. Et c'est vrai que j'ai été au bon endroit, au bon moment à un moment.
Quand tu dis : « Je suis normal, je suis dans la moyenne », tu penses à quoi ?
Que je suis pas meilleur qu'un autre, mais surtout pas moins bon.
Mh.
C'est sûr que j'en connais des moins bons que moi.
Sur quelle échelle, je veux dire moins bon ?
Bah moins travailleur, moins compétent, moins informé, moins prompt à réagir à la seconde, ce qui en radio, évidemment, un peu de répartie, ça sert, avoir un peu de technique, avoir-- voilà, j'ai travaillé.
Maintenant, je suis pas le meilleur, loin de là, mais je suis pas le moins bon.
OK. Et
Et ça, ça me va, en fait, moi j'ai pas besoin d'être le meilleur.
Ça va. Et c'est-- puisqu'on parlait donc de ton travail ici en radio à la RTBF, je me suis posé la question : est-ce qu'être un papa connu, est-ce que ça change quelque chose
pour la vie de tes enfants, pour ta vie à toi, quand tu vas les chercher à l'école ou que sais-je ?
C'est une bonne question. Il y a une valeur de société aujourd'hui qui est étrange, qui est une espèce de truc de célébrité.
Tu passes à la télé--
C'est sûr.
Ou tu connais des gens connus et tout ça. Il y a un truc et surtout, il y a une espèce d'équation très fausse.
C'est : tu passes à la télé ou tu es en radio tous les jours, tu es un homme médiatique, donc tu as réussi. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Les gens s'imaginent souvent que parce que tu passes à la télé, tu as plein d'argent et tu es bien payé, alors que--
Ouais, et puis tu as réussi dans la vie, tu es dans une sphère dans laquelle les autres ne sont pas. Un, c'est faux, c'est pas vrai.
C'est clairement pas vrai. Mais c'est vrai que c'est le récit qui est raconté par notre société. Et c'est vrai que les enfants, et par exemple mes enfants, je sais que de temps en temps, on a eu ces discussions où ils m'ont dit : « Mais...
» quand ils avaient des échecs à l'école, quand ils n'arrivaient pas à faire quelque chose, ils me disaient : « Oui, mais toi, t'y arrives et toi, tu réussis ».
Et en fait, je devais quand même leur expliquer que moi, je n'y arrive pas. Je galère dans tous les sens du terme et que je n'ai pas réussi.
Parce que réussir, c'est quoi ? C'est passer à la télé ? Non, on est bien d'accord.
Avoir une situation stable, avoir--
Oui, mais ma situation n'est pas stable.
Mettre de la nourriture sur la table.
Oui, ça, c'est vrai. Je gagne ma vie, mais je la gagne pas non plus comme un fou. Je suis pas Nagui. Donc--
Tu n'es pas dans la dèche. C'est une forme de réussite à leurs yeux, peut-être.
Oui, voilà. Mais non. Ce qu'ils imaginent, c'est : toi, tu réussis. Comme t'es à la télé, comme t'es au truc, tu réussis tout, toi.
D'accord.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Parce que ça brille un peu.
Ouais, ouais.
Mais c'est faux. Et ils le savent. Ils me voient tous les jours galérer. Mais quand même, quand ils rataient quelque chose, ils me disaient : « Oui, mais tu peux pas comprendre, toi, tu réussis ».
Et donc j'ai quand même dû leur expliquer que non seulement je pouvais comprendre parce qu'en fait, moi non plus, je ne réussissais pas grand-chose de ce que je voulais faire ou de ce que j'imaginais ou à quoi je rêvais.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Moi, mes rêves, je les ai pas atteints. Et donc oui, il y a un truc assez bizarre quand même, même si moi, ma notoriété, elle est douce, ça va, c'est pas...
Tu peux marcher dans la rue sans garde du corps. Tu es--
Oui, oui, oui.
Il t'est déjà arrivé des trucs chelous, des trucs bizarres à cause de ça ou pas ?
Oui, plein. C'est le truc qui m'énerve.
Quels trucs gênants ?
Non, non, c'est pas gênant. C'est juste que je ne comprends pas.
Tu comprends pas.
Je comprends pas le rapport des gens à l'image télévisée ou à... Je ne la comprends pas parce que j'ai pas ça.
J'ai pas ce fantasme-là envers les gens connus ou même un petit peu connus. Donc quand ça m'arrive, et c'est vrai que c'est fréquent, je ne le comprends pas.
Donc c'est pas un truc qui me... Je pense que je l'ai cherché. J'ai dû chercher ça quand j'étais jeune--
D'accord.
À probablement une certaine reconnaissance. Mais une fois que je l'ai expérimenté un petit peu, c'est pas ce qui m'a plu. Non.
C'est ça. Oui, c'est un peu vain en fait, comme projet de vie--
Ah oui, c'est totalement vain. Plus vain, il y a pas, je pense.
Ouais, donc l'autre aspect que tu développes dans le bouquin, c'est la vie de couple.
Voilà.
Le couple qui après, voilà, qui s'est marié relativement tôt.
Oui, c'est pas marié, mais--
Oui, bon, oui.
Qu'on a habité ensemble, qu'on a fait des enfants et--
C'est ça. Comme toi, en fait.
Ouais.
Voilà, qui ont 20 ans de vie commune. Et au bout de 20 ans, après que, voilà, l'adolescence des enfants soit passée par là, c'est de plus en plus tiède, de plus en plus mou--
Mh.
De plus en plus inerte. Est-ce que ça, je repose la question, est-ce que ça, c'est vraiment toi ou est-ce que c'est juste le personnage ?
Mais ça, c'est nous tous.
C'est nous tous ?
Ah oui.
C'est inévitable ?
Bah évidemment, c'est inévitable. C'est pour ça que... Moi, j'ai le fantasme d'une vie à deux longue. Je vois deux vieux qui se tiennent la main--
Ah, romantique.
Ça me met la larme à l'œil, ouais. Et j'ai cette espèce de fantasme-là. Et même s'il y a eu-- ça a été des montagnes russes, j'aime encore la mère de mes enfants, je vis encore avec elle et je l'aime, ça, c'est sûr.
Mais est-ce que c'est facile ? Non. Ce n'est pas facile. C'est-- quand les choses s'empilent, les blessures, parce qu'y a rien à faire, quand on vit vingt ans à côté de quelqu'un, on le blesse et il nous blesse.
Et quand toutes ces blessures s'empilent, quand les petits défauts deviennent des choses insupportables, et ce, tout ça est valable dans les deux sens, évidemment, c'est compliqué.
Et donc c'est un travail de continuer à s'aimer. Il faut y consacrer du temps. On parlait de ça au début, les égoïstes et ceux qui--
D'accord, ouais.
Il faut y consacrer du temps.
C'est ça.
Ça, s'aimer longtemps. Et j'aime pas les gens qui disent que c'est facile de s'aimer.
Il y a des gens qui disent ça ?
Ouais, les gens qui disent : « Ouais, ouais, qui se disputent pas, etc. » Ils font semblant. Je pense qu'ils mentent.
Mh.
Je pense que c'est difficile de s'aimer longtemps. Et c'est difficile de s'aimer longtemps, encore plus probablement avec les vies que nous avons aujourd'hui qui vont très vite, où tout le monde est suroccupé, où il y a de la tension,
il y a de la pression,
avec des enfants en plus.
J'entends des couples de temps en temps qui disent : « Ah, ça va pas très bien, on va faire un enfant pour essayer de recoller tout ça ».
S'il vous plaît, jamais. Un enfant, c'est la pire chose qui arrive à un couple, il faut--
Ouais.
C'est très très beau deux semaines. Après, c'est une épreuve, je veux dire, parce que c'est la fatigue. C'est le début des dilemmes parce qu'on ne veut pas tous éduquer nos enfants de la même façon.
D'accord.
Parce qu'on n'a pas eu la même éducation. Et donc c'est terrible. C'est formidable d'avoir des enfants.
Moi, j'ai trouvé ça formidable. J'ai adoré ça, d'avoir des enfants. Qu'on vienne pas me dire que c'était simple. Non, non, c'est pas simple.
C'est épuisant, c'est intense, ça vous remet en question tout le temps. Ça vous met face à un échec perpétuel parce que vous êtes jamais à la hauteur du père que vous espériez.
Donc oui, oui, c'est compliqué.
Bon évidemment, je regarde ça d'un point de vue absolument amateur, néophyte, extérieur, parce que moi, j'ai pas d'enfant, mais j'ai le sentiment, j'ai l'impression que
le gros changement par rapport aux générations qui nous ont précédés, c'est peut-être, voilà, une culture beaucoup plus,
égalitaire, beaucoup plus féministe aujourd'hui--
Mh.
Qu'il y a cent ans.
Oui, et tant mieux.
Est-ce que-- bien sûr. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est difficile, d'être la première génération parmi tous tes aïeux à remettre en question les rôles genrés et à se libérer de cet héritage-là ?
Bien sûr, c'est quelque chose dont j'ai beaucoup parlé. Moi, je soutiens évidemment pleinement le mouvement féministe.
J'ai lu à ce sujet, j'ai réfléchi à ce sujet. C'est quelque chose que je porte en moi. Ça m'intéresse beaucoup.
Et évidemment, il faut que ça continue et que l'égalité soit obtenue parce qu'il y a des choses, mais on n'y est toujours pas.
Que la domination masculine, bête et méchante, soit supprimée, etc. Par contre, il est très intéressant de parler de la position de l'homme aussi.
Parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup, évidemment, du mouvement de la femme.
Mh.
Et c'est normal, vu que c'est elle qui s'est enlevée de ses chaînes et tant mieux. Mais par contre, c'est vrai qu'avec ce mouvement, ben nous avons bougé aussi.
Et c'est vrai qu'on n'en parle pas beaucoup de c'est quoi d'être un homme aujourd'hui dans cette première génération.
Bah oui.
Je te pose la question--
Et ben--
Qu'est-ce que ça t'a apporté ?
C'est difficile, c'est du pur apprentissage sans avoir eu d'exemple.
Ouais.
C'est-à-dire que moi, je suis clairement pas le père que mon père a été. Je suis plus proche, plus de temps, plus de beaucoup de choses, probablement moins d'autres choses aussi, parce que moi, j'ai eu un père formidable.
Mais je suis pas le même père. On me demande pas d'être le même père. Ma mère n'a pas demandé à mon père ce que ma femme me demande.
Ça, c'est sûr. Et tant mieux, d'ailleurs. Je suis très content de le faire. Mais c'est vrai que je n'ai pas d'exemple paternel du père que je dois être.
Mh.
Et quand je dis « je », c'est nous, c'est toute la génération de pères qui est la mienne. Et on doit apprendre sur le tas.
Et c'est compliqué parce qu'on est un paradoxe complet. C'est-à-dire qu'on va nous demander une tendresse que nous apprenons, une hyper tendresse--
Mh.
Que nous apprenons, pas la tendresse, bon, on l'a toujours eue, mais une hyper tendresse que nous apprenons et en même temps de rester des hommes, des vrais, dans d'autres circonstances.
Et il faut savoir jongler avec ça.
Mh.
Et c'est pas quelque chose de facile. Et--
T'as des exemples concrets de situations où-- de-- un cas comme un autre où dans un cas, on t'a demandé de--
Non, c'est tous les jours. C'est tous les jours.
Ouais.
C'est très bien d'avoir de l'hyper tendresse avec les enfants, avec les autres, avec le bazar, d'être extrêmement attentionné, de pas être l'homme qui rentre du travail et qui pose ses pieds sur la table, évidemment.
Et en même temps, il y a d'autres endroits de la vie, notamment, par exemple, la vie intime, où il va falloir jongler avec tout ça.
Où on te demande encore quand même d'être un mâle. Et tant mieux d'ailleurs, moi, ça me plaît d'être un mâle à certains moments.
C'est--
Mais en--
Ça veut dire quoi, on te demande d'être un mâle ?
C'est vrai que c'est encore une--
Qu'est-ce qu'on te demande ?
Un homme ?
Oui.
Ah ben, on va lui--
Mh.
Ben on va lui demander d'être un homme, par exemple--
Oui, c'est vrai que ça--
Dans la relation sexuelle.
D'accord.
C'est sûr qu'il y a encore un rapport, et c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse dans la relation sexuelle aussi, un rapport de force.
Mh.
Il y a des gens qui n'aiment pas ce rapport de force aujourd'hui dans le discours féministe, de dire que oui, il y a quand même un rapport de force entre deux êtres dans une relation sexuelle.
Il y en a un. C'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait toute la tension. Et la chose bien, c'est qu'il s'inverse de temps en temps. C'est pas homme-femme, c'est pas femme-homme.
Mais évidemment, à des moments, on doit être une chose et pratiquement son contraire. Je trouve ça fascinant.
Je trouve ça compliqué, mais je trouve ça fascinant.
Oui. Donc ça montre bien qu'encore une fois, la culture, la culture genrée, les rôles genrés nous impactent aussi--
Évidemment.
Surtout dans le--
Évidemment, et surtout, ils nous remettent en question et c'est très bien parce qu'on avait vraiment de quoi se remettre en question. Donc oui, c'est une très bonne chose.
Moi, je rends qu'il faut suivre ça, il faut continuer. Mais une fois de plus, dire que c'est facile, non.
Non.
C'est compliqué. Et c'est un des trucs qui m'énerve dans les sociétés dans lesquelles on vit, c'est que tout devrait être facile et on ne devrait pas souffrir.
Et il faut sourire comme sur Instagram et dire : « Regardez, ma vie est belle ». Non, non, en fait on galère pas mal.
Ouais.
Et moi, c'est pour ça que j'écris des livres et c'est pour ça que j'en lis autant. C'est parce que dans les livres, enfin, beaucoup plus que sur Instagram, je vois des gens qui souffrent.
Et ça me rassure vachement parce que moi, je souffre aussi.
Et c'est tout ce qui m'énerve sur les réseaux sociaux, cette espèce de mystification absolue des vies de chacun qui fait que quand toi, t'es tout seul derrière ton ordinateur et que tu galères, tu dis : Putain, je suis le seul à galérer.
Regarde, ils sont tous heureux, ils sont tous à Tahiti avec des filles sublimes et plein d'argent dans les poches.
Or, la vérité, c'est pas ça. La vérité, moi, je la trouve plus dans les livres que je lis. Et dans les livres que je lis, par contre, je vois des miroirs et je me sens moins seul.
Et quand je dis je, c'est nous, évidemment, c'est moi aussi. Et donc c'est à la fois tout ce que je déteste des réseaux sociaux, que je hais, alors que j'y participe hein.
Bah oui.
Mais je les déteste.
J'allais dire : Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ? Qu'est-ce que tu fais sur Twitter alors ?
Alors, ce que je fais sur Twitter, je m'informe. Mais c'est tout. Je ne like pratiquement rien, sinon un petit truc comme ça qui me correspond ou bazar.
Et je fais de la, c'est honteux, de l'autopromotion. Je promotionne mes émissions de télé, mes émissions-
Communication.
Et mes émissions de radio et mes bouquins. Mais à part ça, c'est vrai que je n'y trouve pas d'intérêt. Je n'aime pas ce sens de la communauté fausse.
S'informer et communiquer sur soi, c'est pas-
Oui oui oui. Mais c'est vrai que c'est très égoïste. Mon utilisation des réseaux sociaux est extrêmement égoïste. C'est pour faire la promo de ce que je fais.
Vraiment, j'avoue. Je n'y suis pas par intérêt d'être dans un réseau ou une communauté parce que je trouve que ni le réseau ni la communauté n'existent, vu que ce n'est que du mensonge.
Ce n'est que du mensonge.
Et donc, ben ouais, il n'y a que du mensonge.
Ça dépend des gens que tu suis.
Non, non, non, non. Ce qui m'intéresse dans les réseaux sociaux, je lis la presse. Ce qui m'intéresse dans les réseaux sociaux, c'est la vie des autres.
Moi, ce qui m'intéresse, et on en revenait tout à l'heure, c'est quoi vivre ? C'est quelle relation je vais avoir avec les autres.
C'est ça qui m'intéresse, moi, dans la vie. Lire le journal, alors je lis le journal. J'ai pas besoin des réseaux sociaux, j'ai pas besoin d'Internet.
La vie des autres, c'est ça qui m'intéresse. Or, la vie des autres sur les réseaux sociaux, franchement, bullshit, c'est pas vrai.
C'est pas vrai. Moi, je vois la vie que certaines personnes que je connais montrent sur Instagram et je connais leur vraie vie, c'est pas la même.
Franchement, c'est pas la même. C'est même relativement diamétralement opposé.
On est d'accord. Et du coup, toi, en tant que père, l'éducation de tes enfants, est-ce que tu leur parles des réseaux sociaux ?
Est-ce que tu leur dis surtout-
Oh évidemment.
Surtout, calmez-vous avec ça.
Ils ne font que ça.
Ouais, ouais.
Ils ne font que ça. Ils sont sur YouTube d'un côté et les réseaux sociaux de l'autre. Donc oui, oui, évidemment, on a de très très très nombreuses discussions à ce sujet.
C'est très compliqué parce qu'une fois de plus, qui devrait le faire ? Les parents, bien sûr, mais les parents ne sont pas tous éduqués, donc l'école.
Or, l'école ne fait rien
par rapport à ça. Ils ne savent pas ce que c'est une image,
ils ne savent pas décortiquer une image, ils ne savent pas ce que c'est un réseau social, ils savent pas que Facebook revend leurs données, ils savent pas ce que c'est des données personnelles.
L'école ne leur explique pas. C'est hallucinant, mais l'école ne leur explique pas. Donc moi, je le fais parce que j'ai la chance de savoir un petit peu de quoi ça parle, mais tous les parents, ben malheureusement, ne sont pas dans ce cas-là.
Donc, on va encore créer une fracture, là. C'est pas bien. Mais par contre, j'ai beau essayer de leur expliquer : Attention à ce que tu postes, ça restera toujours.
Quelle photo, quel vocabulaire, quelle faute d'orthographe, quelle image tu donnes de toi. Tu sais qu'un jour, quelqu'un pourra aller voir ça quand il cherchera à t'engager.
Et ils le feront, ne t'inquiète pas. Qu'est-ce que tu envoies en message privé ? C'est quoi un message privé ? Est-ce que tu penses vraiment qu'un message privé, c'est privé ou la personne à qui tu l'envoies peut le rendre public ou
d'autres personnes qui gèrent cette plateforme peuvent, eux,
absorber tes photos.
Est-ce que tu es au courant ? Oui, oui, oui, on parle de ça. Mais c'est vrai que par rapport à leur ultra-utilisation de la chose, leur connaissance de la chose est assez faible.
Donc, on doit en parler beaucoup.
On n'explique pas Cambridge Analytica à l'école parce qu'on ne comprend pas Cambridge Analytica.
Mais non, mais il faudrait. Non, mais il faudrait parce que c'est en train de changer le monde. On a vu l'impact que ça a eu, par exemple, Cambridge Analytica sur les élections aux États-Unis.
Donc oui, ça change le monde. Donc oui, il faut que l'école en parle.
C'est tout le drame de-- on va bientôt devoir se quitter, mais c'est tout le drame de notre époque, c'est que les problèmes qu'on connaît sont très complexes.
Les manipulations d'élections, les manipulations de données personnelles à très grande échelle, la surveillance de masse, tout ça.
Et en fait, les gens ne comprennent pas.
Non.
Et je remarque en fait, aux élections, on parle pas tellement-
On n'en parle même pas.
Des manipulations des élections par Vladimir Poutine, etc. C'est...
Non, on ne parle pas de ça parce que le problème est visiblement trop complexe pour que nous, citoyens idiots, puissions éventuellement le comprendre.
Est-ce que toi, tu vois ça comme ta mission au service public, la RTBF, informer, continuer le-- faire le boulot que l'école ne fait pas et apprendre aux gens ce qu'ils ne voient pas ?
Non. Moi, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est les livres, les chansons, les films, etc. Et ce qui m'intéresse dans les livres, les chansons, les films, etc, c'est pas la leçon de politique.
C'est apprendre un petit peu comment fonctionne le monde, oui, mais c'est qu'est-ce qui nous relie aux autres. Qu'est-ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains ? Et
ma perception, qu'est-ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains, c'est la relation que j'ai avec toi, c'est la relation que j'ai avec elle, c'est la relation que j'ai avec eux,
c'est la relation que j'ai avec le groupe, la société dans laquelle je vis, le pays dans lequel je vis.
C'est nos relations interpersonnelles. Et moi, mon but, quand je fais de la radio, c'est parler de ça. C'est nous relier.
C'est le seul-- moi, j'éduque personne hein, vraiment, mais le seul espoir que j'ai quand je le fais, c'est qu'on se relie un petit peu plus à travers cette émission-là, qu'on va lire le même livre et qu'on va partager les mêmes émotions.
Et donc demain, on pourra en parler si on se croise. Et juste essayer de relier les gens plutôt que de les séparer.
Moi, c'est mon seul objectif professionnel.
C'est un magnifique mot de la fin. Tu vas devoir aller animer Entrez sans frapper-
C'est vrai.
Dans un instant dans le studio d'à côté.
Ouais.
On va se quitter là-dessus. Jérôme Colin, merci beaucoup.
Bah merci à toi.
D'avoir passé cinquante-neuf minutes avec moi.
Ouais, on n'a pas tenu la promesse du titre hein, désolé.
Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode avec Jérôme Colin. Alors oui, je sais que c'est un petit peu court, mais voilà, Jérôme devait filer en studio pour animer son émission.
Je vous avais promis quelques annonces, alors les voilà. Dans deux semaines, je recevrai Hugues Dayet, le comparse de Rudy Léoney, que j'avais déjà reçu en mars.
On a déjà enregistré ça. C'est dans la boîte. On a parlé de l'industrie du cinéma, de l'exception culturelle, de Netflix, de tout ça.
Et on a aussi parlé de son fils Thomas,
qui est autiste Asperger. C'était très intéressant d'entendre un parent s'exprimer sur le sujet dans la continuité de, voilà, l'épisode spécial autisme qu'on a fait il y a deux semaines où j'interviewais deux cliniciens.
Un très bon épisode, donc, que je vous encourage à ne pas rater. Et pour ça, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme préférée, que ce soit iTunes, YouTube, Spotify, Pocket Cast ou tout ce que vous voulez,
et sur les réseaux sociaux, puisque tous les liens sont dans la description.
Enfin, ce sera bientôt le retour de la politique dans cette émission, puisque j'ai déjà booké un paquet de politiciens et de journalistes à l'occasion des élections.
Allez, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Salut !